[Music]
you know the other day i was feeling
particularly weary
so i started humming as spiritual as one
does when one feels weary
and i thought wow i wish there were some
modern day spirituals that reflect our
current times
so i wrote some and i recorded them onto
an album
introducing now that's what i call
spirituals 20 21
57 tracks that contain the soul of the
past but the trauma of today
with such hits as wait
in the wage gap wait in the wage gap
children
wait in the wage gap
we're all poor because of the wage gap
we are in the middle of history being
made every day our music should reflect
it
and this cd will do exactly that with
tracks like
swing low sweet male
man coming with my stimulus check
do you feel the spirit if not you're
about to because
these songs put a new twist on old
classics like
oppressing black folks without an end
let my people go bite and
bite and let my people go
to therapy for free
we even have a few tracks for the
children children go
where i send thee how shall i send thee
then
i'm gonna send them one by one to mass
and hand sanitizer with one bulletproof
vest
when school schools open
back up if you're looking for songs that
will bring you closer to heaven
while also reminding you of the very
sobering details of life on earth
then look no further than now that's
what i call spirituals 20 21
i'll really miss the mountains the
oceans the hills and
everywhere cause due to climate change
they soon will be gone
now that's what i call spirituals 2021
order your copy today
[Music]
you